how about a ride mister sure but look
are you
also is this movie recognizing that
Marty's trip back to 1955 would have
changed a hell of a lot more lives than
just a handful because Jennifer Parker
turned into Elisabeth Shue you're acting
like you haven't seen me in a week how
about ever now what happens to us in the
future what are we becoming assholes or
something since this is a reshoot of the
first movies ending filmmakers decide
they need doc to react to this famous
quote indicate dammit hey doc you better
back up
we're not have enough run to get up to
88 part runs mistake becomes Park twos
mistake I could get up to 88 in a Prius
with that much wrote - Jennifer so
willing to immediately hop into the
DeLorean without one question asked what
the hell is going on here only Biff in
the entire neighborhood sees this hey
October 21st 2015 hey that's the day of
this video's launch what a coincident
it's not a coincidence Wow why wasn't I
told about this
we were in the future did they feel
Michael J Fox his first table read into
this movie just a sleep-inducing awful
rhythm generator
she's asking so many questions that
maybe you shouldn't have ridiculously
crashed into Marty's driveway and
allowed her in the car in the first
place well you didn't seem to think it
was a big deal when you told Marty bring
her along also and this is not an
original point by any means but why do
they have to go to the Future to change
things when doc could simply tell Marty
in 1985 how things are and to avoid
making bad decisions what did you bring
her for how'd it do something how about
using the sleep-inducing thing back in
1985 and put her to bed you really
didn't think this through did you screen
right I mean doc Wow Marty somehow
produced a child with Jennifer that
contained none of her DNA cubs sweep
series and five did they think the world
series would be nine games by the time
2015 rolled around hey what what about
Jennifer we're not just gonna leave her
here actually you are and it turns out
exactly as such a bad idea should turn
out
apparently John's 19 will be directed by
Mack Spielberg Stephen son this must
mean the family is in serious dire
straits to take such a whoremongering
gig all I want is it peps do you pay for
anything in this diner
how did pussy Biff from 1985 ever get
around to procreating the guy was in his
late 40s definitely with no kids but for
the purposes of the sequel he manages to
find one willing female to marry into
his lucrative auto detailing empire and
that kid also had a kid he's Griff yeah
something that doc didn't tell you for
some reason when he hatched this
half-assed plan to use your hands
discount baby Frodo that's why did you
wait on the physical type remember when
gremlins two came out it was basically a
parody of the first gremlins why did
they do that get back to the future
What's Wrong McFly chicken thus begins
an incredibly ridiculous trigger word
that the next two movies will use to
advance the plot several times
thankfully for Marty riffs henchmen were
watching this fight in a single-file
line for some reason hey let's do
everything we did in the first back of
the future only 2015 style with 1989
knowledge for you hoverboards a
skateboarder gains momentum in
propulsion because his foot hits the
ground and pushes off not because he
waves it about behind him in the air so
why does it help these fucking things go
faster wow this ex machina Jeep is the
gift that keeps on getting me by you
Paul job boss don't work on water
you've got power well it's still
hovering right why does it still have
power to hover but not move and a
Griffis supposed to be not too bright
but this the third time Marty has fooled
him by simply ducking in the last five
minutes I got it hit for now how nothing
clearly flew into the building you were
not a first responder on the scene and
could not possibly have gotten all the
way back here faster than Marty did
anyway Cubs won World Series this is an
intriguing thing that as of this video's
production can still happen if it does
feel free to remove 20 sins from this
video because that is one hell of a
prediction right now we know why they
just left Jennifer in Denali so this
movie had a completely unnecessary way
to have more conflict if managed to be
in the perfect random place to not only
hear about the time machine but get his
hands on the sports Almanac
movie thinks it is upside down we won't
notice a discount Crispin Glover and you
know what teenage me he did not but sin
me did so why does the scenery channel
appear to be showing its viewers pause
VHS tapes of scenery
lately landing in an O landing zone
can't risk you run against your older
self why take the dog is it just so the
DeLorean will be completely empty when
Biff steals it because I think it is yes
he tells him to go find Jennifer but
since when is that dog a bloodhound okay
I want channels 18 24 60 397 in one
why does it refer to all the other
channels by their numbers but asks
specifically for the Weather Channel
several things here Marty ignores Doc's
instructions yet again and does not stay
with the car also he doesn't lock the
car or even shut the goddamn door
does Biff no he needs to blast this
thing to 88 miles per hour to time
travel
how about working the dashboard so that
it knows where to go in the future metal
will not conduct heat so you can touch
it with your bare hands
feed my house they still use faxes well
to the thing he ignored your orders to
stay with the car since you now need his
help
it comes back after giving younger Biff
the sports Almanac but nothing in this
future has changed at all it should be
the nightmarish bit future right now
it leaves ridiculous evidence proving he
used the time machine so the doc and
Marty can figure out what the hell
happened when they go to bizarro 1985 as
we see Biff went back to November 12
1955 how do Marty and Doc miss this
after a jet flew by but not have jets in
2015 or any other non 1985 era
I remember bars being on these windows
freely how often do you go to your own
girlfriend's house that bars on windows
is something that should be black and
white not fuzzy and beige they don't
notice the subdivision graffiti either
Jesus it takes these two way too long to
realize the past has been changed wait
why did they leave 1985 in the morning
but return to it at night why not just
go back to the moment you left like
every other time in these movies Marta
comes back to a house that is no longer
hiss but thankfully there's a window
left open so he could discover the truth
a lot sooner and in more embarrassing
fashion the Sandra father swings and
misses Marty three times in a row
mostly because each swing starts long
after Maria's move despite a massive
worldwide change due to Biff scambling
success way back in 1958 Michael Jackson
still somehow made thriller and off the
wall exactly as he did in the normal
timeline Marty is now recognizing all
the wrong appearing he ignored on the
drive flight into town Marty just
happens to find the random house where
principal Strickland lives because
nostalgia last week the school burnt out
six years ago and they didn't build
another one these assholes hate the
principal so much that they're still
angry enough to try and kill him in a
drive-by six years after they've been
required by anyone to even attend school
that is a serious grudge the thing
bullets don't go through wood or else
Marty would be dead dedicated to Hill
valleys number one citizen it's at this
point that Marty should already be
zooming on over to Doc Brown's place to
stop him from tearing the time machine
apart
amazing history of the Tannen family
starting with his great-grandfather
Buford Mad Dog Tannen see this is the
kind of awesome foreshadowing in
cohesion you can get when you film
sequels simultaneously third time's a
charm Lorraine who was never into Biff
marries him anyway because of something
vague about financial troubles or some
oh and to give an emotional reason for
Marty to change this future ah no you're
safe and sound now this whole movie is
throwback so the last one
Oak Park Cemetery Marty doesn't believe
his mother so he needs to physically see
his father's tombstone for proof which
won't actually prove anything more about
George being dead than his mother's work
if you really want proof you got to dig
that shit up dude you come here so you
found out Marty's dad died at the exact
same time already found out
that's amazing time go into the public
library they're trying to make sense out
all the madness and helpfully George
McFly murder was front-page news so that
you could easily reference and reunite
with Marty in a timely fashion and shade
the book to himself at some point in the
past
yeah but why was he allowed to return to
the original timeline while these two
got sucked into the old version it says
right here that this made his first
million betting on a horse race in 1958
the sports Almanac has winners from
minor horse races in 1958 it's like 90
pages also it doesn't say anything about
Biff winning money in the actual
articles just a bunch of vague gibberish
that I'm sure some temp is hired to
write for fake movie newspapers Nixon to
seek fifth term somebody's read Watchmen
crazy old codger with a cane show so he
says he's my distant relative I don't
see any resemblance myth has literally
zero reason to tell Marty any of this
what the hell is that still works it
couldn't match up the bullet that killed
your old man you were firing at him
earlier now your monologuing good for
you Marty Biff can still shoot you right
also how did doc know to be around the
roof at this time not to mention once
again risking everyone seeing that
flying car again if is not leaning far
enough over this ledge for this car door
to hit it unbelievable that ol Biff
could have chosen that particular date
really not if you want to bask in the
glow of the first movie again this
Halton in 1985 will be changed back into
the real 1985
isn't it great you can just time travel
your problems away without creating
entirely new problems from the time
travel a walkie-talkie so we can keep in
contact when the did you buy those and
how the hell does Marty open that
plastic packaging with practically
negative effort you must
very careful not to run into your other
self that's another thing this went back
to 1955 and a flying DeLorean and
apparently no one saw that do you think
Biff would have been as careful to hide
the car walk his 78 year old ass to town
to find his younger self Marty trails
bifid a distance and in a manner that
should have resulted in Biff spotting
and pummeling him blocks ago the manure
remember that why wouldn't you remember
that it literally tries to lift up
Lorraine's skirt on the downtown square
in broad daylight and no one cares but
Lorraine old Biff is still behind that
tree remembering the manure incident
fondly instead of watching the scene
unfold which would reveal to him that
Marty is in the back of the car is he
doing behind that tree anyway Marty here
on the right is somehow not in bits
peripheral vision announcer makes the
most preposterous statement ever made in
a sporting event during the very moment
UCLA is actually coming out to kick a
field goal that could win the game if
absolutely had to look in the back seat
to see where this book landed and yet he
totally misses Marty wait does this car
have no rearview mirror well that's
convenient to the action that needs to
take place right and now it does have a
rearview mirror doc that Rick how the
hell does Biff not hear this he's not
even really whispering Marty he must be
extremely careful not to run into your
other self says the man standing
literally in the center of his other
selfs lightning experiment from 1955 doc
has seen 1985 Doc's face and voice which
he knows we're watching that damn video
over and over in the last movie so not
noticing his future self here is both
the Apollo having a five a six friends
have two bucks why you are not busy
holding something together that you
can't get the rent yourself Universal
reuse this Crispin Glover footage
without his permission
which rightfully led to a successful
lawsuit and new regulations there's no
reason why doc and Marty needed to risk
anything tonight it took three years for
BIC to win his millions at the horse
race so why not wait till a much better
time to get the Almanac back I mean
Jesus have you ever seen a movie this
fucking clever this entire movie is
possible because people don't notice
goddamn Marty is able to take my life
pain damage to his hand without making
any noise when Marty aka Calvin Klein be
such a superstar here in 1955
even in a leather jacket and hat
everyone would know he was the one that
sucker punched at down Biff and stole
his wallet and book guys what's that
this is literally the only move Marty
McFly has in his arsenal and it still
works why the fuck did he come back here
does he just need more nostalgia
where's Oh Calvin Klein so doesn't this
mean that Biff doesn't become a pussy
after this he does after one lucky
but from George but he sees Marty punch
him and he's suddenly back to being an
asshole
you know what I'd do I'd go over and tap
those guys on the shoulder and then
start running again besides even if you
get beat up you have all the time in the
world this is not like the first movie
when there was a deadline
these henchmen who are literally staring
at Marty are unable to see Marty oh look
there's a convenient number of goon
busting sandbags all tied together at
this one spot that was very interesting
music what is the deal with the weird
new line readings I mean didn't they
want to even get close to the originals
how and why does every adversary Marty
Encounters know exactly what button to
push good thing this is one of those
chases where only the principal
characters are driving down the road at
this very moment that'll teach Biff
seems to be glad about committing murder
and he doesn't the least bit care that
he just did more than 300 bucks damage
to his car right there after this
somehow Marty doesn't even have a black
eye or bloody nose or anything this is
the second time in this movie that doc
is ex machina Marty from an aggressive
Biff via the flying DeLorean Jesus what
are the odds hitting a manure truck mere
days after you hit the last one on this
road at this hour have to be akin to
discovering proof of Pluto on Mars marty
is somehow able to light a match in this
windy storm which is maybe the least
believable thing in all three of these
movies yeah yeah no more pleasure palace
but the exact same matchbook wouldn't be
cooler if the whole matchbook just
disappeared same here why would he have
been honored on that same day would it
be cooler if it just told us someone
else got murdered doc continues flying
the time machine in the dangerous
lightning storm long after dropping off
marty and for no particularly good
reason other than setting up the sequel
oh also you could just wait until
tomorrow I'm just saying it there's no
reason to risk anything right now why
doesn't anyone know this here is one of
the only sequels ever to actually
include a trailer for the third movie as
part of the end of this movie weird
no it's Hill Dali although I can imagine
he'll be much worse
pick ramakrishna through a card think
about the future
you suck yet jackass don't with the
babysitter so he says how would you like
to be rich and he said how'd you like to
make twenty five thousand dollars and I
said who wouldn't